Earlier this year, we covered a story out of Sanger, Texas
about a grocery store built inside of a high school
with a surprising twist.
They don't accept money.
The only currency they use is good deeds.
We were so inspired by this story that we wanted to
do a follow-up and we may have a follow-up on that follow-up
and some more surprise twists in store,
but first take a look.
Anthony Love the principal of
Linda Tutt High School joins us
now I'm very excited to meet him.
Welcome Anthony.
You have your students pay with good deeds.
What's your advice on what good deeds are?
That could be going above and beyond in the classroom.
That could be being a positive mentor
or just a friend to another student
who's having a hard time.
There is no limit for the possibilities
or ways that schools can have a program like this.
We, here at the show, would just love to get involved.
I'm so personally inspired by what you are doing.
I do see endless possibilities for your program.
(audience clapping)
And here we are back with us again.
It's Principal Anthony Love.
(audience clapping)
Hello
Hi Principal Love
How is everything going?
What's the latest and greatest
with your high school grocery store paid with good deeds?
So the store has been great, students.
All the time students want to volunteer or
be a part of it somehow.
Up-to-date, we've been able to help close
to 350 families, which comes out to a little more
than 15 hundred people
that we've been able to help
with food insecurities.
That's what I was going to say as much
as this is such a poetic, lofty
brilliant way to bring out the best in people.
You're also helping people who are food insecure.
I think what you're doing is game-changing in every way.
And when you were last here, you told us
that you wanted to see
good deed grocery stores replicated
in other school districts and Delay Middle School
in Lewisville, Texas heard about your story
and they wanted to follow in your footsteps.
And we have the Delay Middle School principal here
Charde Dockery, Principal Dockery.
Hi
(audience clapping)
Principal Dockery I'm so happy to meet you.
How do you think that a good deed grocery store could work
and benefit inside of your school?
Oh, wow. So Delay Middle School,
we're about 90% economically disadvantaged,
which means most of our students
receive free reduced lunch.
A lot of our families are living in low-income housing.
From a trailer home communities to budget suites, and some
of them are actually homeless.
So they do not have access to just kind of fresh organic
or healthy foods just within their
immediate community.
And I just, I saw Principal Love's story,
and even the pieces on kindness and
empathy and just servant leadership.
Our students definitely need that experience
because they do not have those experiences
in their communities and they don't travel outside
of their two mile radius, often.
Principal Love,
Do you have any advice,
may I ask, since you've done it?
So you got to have a champion for the grocery store.
You gotta have somebody who believes in it
sees the vision and you just have to have
the mindset that failure is not an option.
There'll be things come up that you're not expecting
but you just have to have a team with you that is there
to support you and to support the students.
Hmm. That sounds like really honest
and real world advice, find the right people
and expect the unexpected.
There's not a reference for this.
And we wanted to help turn this dream
into reality and spread the love.
So here to join us is Catherine Oliveros
the Vice President
of Community Health Improvement
at Texas Health Resources.
And they are the largest nonprofit health system
in North Texas and their program
has been going beyond the walls
of their hospitals and into their communities.
Hi Catherine, thank you so much for joining us today.
(audience clapping)
Thank you Drew it's great to join you.
Catherine. I was wondering
if you had something to say to Principal Dockery.
I do.
I am so excited to share some great news
with Principal Dockery.
I'm pleased to announce today
that Texas Health in collaboration
with Albertsons will be donating $30,000 to
Delay Middle School so
that Principal Dockery can replicate the good deed
grocery store in their community.
(audience clapping)
Thank you, that is a blessing.
Thank you so much.
We are so happy to be apart this Principle Dockery
as a faith based nonprofit health system
Texas Health is dedicated to providing quality clinical care
across all our access points.
So congratulations.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you so much.
Such a blessing
Principal Dockery I wanted to also let you know
that our friends at Omaha Steaks heard about your story
and they're also going to donate another $10,000
towards your schools grocery store.
(audience clapping)
Thank you. Thank you
Oh that's not all,
they're also going to throw in $4,000 worth
of steak snacks for your students and the staff at school.
(audience clapping)
Oh my gosh. Thank you so much. Wow.
Catherine, thank you so much
for contributing to this program.
You are the seed of change
for this school and Principal Dockery.
Thank you so much.
And to Omaha Steaks, who's also playing such a big part
in this and to Principal Love,
You really are the genius that made this all possible
and I'm so in awe
of watching a potential domino effect happen
and I'll do anything I can to
just be a part of that.
I think what you've done is incredible.
Well, thank you.
Okay. Thank you guys.
(upbeat music)